cada 4 segundos a una persona se le
diagnostica la enfermedad de alzheimer
es la causa más común de demencia ya que
afecta a más de 40 millones de personas
en todo el mundo y los investigadores
aún no le han encontrado cura el doctor
alois alzheimer un psiquiatra alemán
describió los síntomas por primera vez
en 1901 cuando se percató de que una
paciente de un hospital tenía ciertos
problemas que incluían dificultad para
dormir problemas de memoria cambios de
humor drásticos y una confusión
creciente cuando la paciente falleció
alzhéimer pudo realizar la autopsia y
comprobar su idea de que quizá sus
síntomas se debían a irregularidades en
la estructura cerebral lo que descubrió
bajo el microscopio fueron diferencias
visibles en el tejido cerebral bajo la
forma de proteínas mal plegadas llamadas
placas seniles y ovillos neurofibrilares
estas placas y ovillos actúan juntos
para destruir la estructura del cerebro
las placas aparecen cuando otra proteína
de la membrana grasa que rodea las
células nerviosas es separada por una
enzima concreta lo que da lugar a
proteínas beta amiloides que son
pegajosas y tienden a agruparse
estos depósitos son los que forman lo
que conocemos como placas seniles que
bloquean las señales y por tanto la
comunicación entre células también
desencadenan reacciones autoinmunes que
destruyen las células nerviosas dañadas
en el mal de alzhéimer los ovillos
neurofibrilares se forman a partir de
una proteína conocida como tau las
neuronas del cerebro están formadas por
una red de ramificaciones que actúa como
una autopista para las moléculas de los
alimentos entre otras cosas normalmente
la proteína tau se encarga de que estas
ramificaciones estén rectas para
permitir que las moléculas circulen
libremente sin embargo con el alzheimer
la proteína queda reducida a hebras u
ovillos que causan la destrucción de las
ramificaciones e impiden que los
nutrientes lleguen a las células
nerviosas y esto provoca su muerte la
unión destructiva de las placas y los
ovillos comienza en una zona conocida
como el hipocampo que es el responsable
de formar los recuerdos por ello la
pérdida de memoria a corto plazo es
habitualmente el primer síntoma de
alzheimer las proteínas invaden
progresivamente otras partes del cerebro
lo que crea cambios particulares que
indican los distintos estados
enfermedad en la parte delantera del
cerebro las proteínas destruyen la
habilidad de procesar pensamientos
lógicos después se mueven a la zona que
controla las emociones lo que provoca
cambios de humor erráticos en la parte
superior del cerebro causan paranoia de
alucinaciones y cuando llegan a la parte
trasera del cerebro las placas y los
ovillos actúan juntos para borrar los
recuerdos más profundos de la mente
finalmente el centro de control que
dirige el ritmo cardíaco y la
respiración sucumben también y provocan
la muerte la naturaleza inmensamente
destructiva de esta enfermedad ha
motivado a muchos investigadores a
buscar una cura pero actualmente se
centran en reducir su avance un
tratamiento temporal ayuda a reducir la
destrucción de acetilcolina un
importante neurotransmisor del cerebro
que disminuyen los pacientes de
alzheimer debido a la muerte de las
células nerviosas que la producen otra
posible solución es una vacuna que
enseña el sistema inmunológico atacar a
las placas de beta amiloides antes de
que formen depósitos sin embargo aún
tenemos que encontrar una cura real la
enfermedad de alzheimer se descubrió
hace más de un siglo y todavía
no se comprende del todo quizás un día
entendamos los mecanismos exactos que se
desarrollan detrás de esta amenaza y
hallaremos una solución